[Music]
on my birthday
played so much mortal kombat 11.
my god i love this game this game's so
fun
and after many years of playing mortal
kombat i finally
figured out how to properly get the
fatalities done
in certain characters took me a long
time
and then i was like whoa what's happened
today
i've always felt like i've always just
gotten lucky you
achieved a character arc but now it's
been uh almost a month since i last
played anywho
let's watch this
[Music]
sub sub sub zero
speak
[Music]
that's great that's great that's my
favorite one
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's it another three you got a
gazillion characters man
have every character get one even the
dlc characters should get one i mean you
already got some you know horror
characters already in there
characters that are perfectly fit for
halloween hell you even got joker there
he's dressed for the party already he's
dressed for every halloween party
for the past decades yeah and every
comic-con event but i feel like you can
get even kind of crazier man you got to
give some more people some other crazier
outfits
john improvised well yeah because i
don't know there are so many
monstrous characters i thought even at
least goro or somebody would show up
even
more insane you know i don't know i
liked these three ideas
i love the johnny cage one a lot the
giant cage one's perfect that seems like
the perfect
match of whimsy fun monster i mean the
devorah one's really cool
yeah i feel like they could have just
done more stuff like time for ratchet
exactly exactly what i'm gonna do is put
ratchet on in the background and then
play mortal kombat
yeah but yeah i've got him in the same
boat i'm like these are really cool now
where where's the rest this was a nice
sample i mean they're skins i feel like
you can go a little bit crazier turn
someone into a vampire yeah turn this i
don't know how you would do that
frankenstein monster or
uh or a wendigo no no i'm thinking about
it it's kind of hard to
apply all these things there's tons of
ways to more
character is more horrifying there's so
much horror in moral combat to begin
with
the blizzard king one was i mean that
looks cool but it doesn't look
really halloweeny to me yeah the other
two do the other two definitely do i
like the design yeah but it didn't say
spooky yeah i just say halloween
different
you know different takeouts like this
looks like it's another alternate option
i could have had it
at this point you could have just done
scorpion and made him like have actual
scorpion or something like that but
still
thank you guys for all the hard work
you're putting in the mortal kombat you
guys have been delivering
respect to the animators i'm sure it
takes a lot of work
all right guys we'll catch you guys soon
what do you think about these skins
leave suggestions down below what other
types of skins you'd like to see
subscribe click the bells blah blah blah
bye